新年明けましておめでとうございますはず味噌長です
a
こんな新年早々あまり復興の話をしたくはないんですけれどもまぁ事実としてこちらに
言わせていただきます
2020年度に入って
早
2階
交通事項
応募しました誠に申し訳ございませんでした
[音楽]
まあ僕ではないんですけどどう
ん
照明塔さんありがとうございますハイツ寄せように
aa って思いましたよ僕は本当にすいませんでしょ
事情説明版で頂けますとこちらの一般男性の方い
ニッセン20年に入ってるんですよそういうあのまず1回目
はい元旦に地元の友人等
初詣入っ
っていうサ一番簡単なんです渋滞が生なんですね細かくは良いですはい
実行されてないと言うのでまあそうですね1回目事故がありました
1番での2回目が8月4日にはいまたぁ
今度をぶつけまして
笑い事じゃないのとじゃあもし訓示が本当に危ないですからねはい来られるんでました
最速ですよ
やっぱり強またまた2020年始まってまだ一週間もぐらいですよ
そういう週間ぐらいですけど
れっ週にヤバイで主演にペンで事故ると本当にやばいすごいんていいもあの僕去年から
8都市なんですけども
僕が今まで水設定でやってきた中でタブー
一番[ __ ]が張るんですよ本当に
えっ皆さん本当にすごいんですよわざわざドアにするくらいなんてです今のでわかると
思うんですけどもう今年で2回も事故ってるんですよね命に別状がなかったのは何故
ですよねあなたも相手さんを持ってですけどほんと事故だけ気を付けて下さい今気を
つけますところってたらニュースになりますからねそういう音それだけでも一番気を
つけてます持った運転手動くのってたら僕
事故にあるようなニュースになるねほんとなますようわが4月も本当にもう事故は絶対
しません
ずぼだけじゃなくてもまあもう父母会はプライズ去年もを色々
口寒気でちょっとあの彼がどれくらい運が悪いかっていうのをちょっと遡ってみ
ましょう
今日は体力差がありました良ければいいのあのでかいもドーンとより細い運の悪さが
au へ続くタイプなんてホント
そうです大蛇東京のとある撮影に入っに行かせていただいた時にはもう
最善のチェックをした上でいかずカメラのバッテリーだけ忘れてたとか
いやそう
それ本当に申し訳形にや巨大クリスマスツリーはい動画でも
今回はそのバッテリー諸々は全部揃ってたんですね
カメラの根元につける接続部分来ないですね自在ですねあれだけオスれるのか
それも万全なチェックした上でとかさなちゃんめっちゃ効いた所北高校の部活やってる
ときに
あったそれだそれどうぞ自分ビックリしましたけど
僕もともとから体をずっと長くやらせていただいていて高校の時も
からて部に在籍させて頂いんですよでまぁ僕の一個上の際が引退して
[音楽]
ブーブー僕なんかを殺す後輩
がボイコットして来なかったんせ人にも6月にたまたまその部員と出会ってなんでこ
ないんだってなったときにはちょっともうメジャーでパッチリ県もったい
この結果ぼっち先輩には毎日嬲られていましたって言う
また実はりの話を作られて顧問に持ちかけられて
そまあまあ
みんなが言うこと習っ信じ込んでそんな奴にはもう部長は課せられるということでまぁ
3カ月で部長退任
って言う
本当は殴りました本当に殴ったがですこの項の形で肩パンとか言われん
設置していたくないと言いたくないですよでかいのもつながるんですけどバカに不幸が
めちゃくちゃ多いですよねいや本当には皆さんが思っている以上に彼はすごい不幸なん
ですよ
ゴチさんが畑に出ると援助するんですよそういや本当にそれに関してはこっちの
ブーブー多分
何かしらの立場です
行いなやったねゲて目思考なんですが結構ほんと苦手ですね怖いんで僕はちょっと著
なお伏せさせていただいてどうがっでてもらってるんですけどなぁそう
一般男性としてここでもバレないんでこの冬にあった人形
ああもう怖されません考案されました本当にそれを申し訳なくアートあれですよ
などが住んだ放送
まあ絨毯あれも遅刻しましたねそうでさホワイトボード頼んでうん
そのから送っても大丈夫です
タイヤの部分だけ破損しててはれたと
めっちゃを疑ったすよ一応ずんって自分で打ってくれ
届いたらアンコール知っては競ってファーストジャンルから
部そんな力ないですからねあーからベルだ何言ってもうこういったことを買ったらもう
俺様も届くんですよ
もちろんだポケモンそうシールだっていうとき本当に通信でやったじゃないですかはい
その時なんかメロそれを背負ってまでやってこれなんかをはじめさんもげないですね
えって言って僕同社の子ちゃんも出てるんですよ
なんでだろうとの子さん不思議ですねはるこさんを見たらブロックリストに入ってい
ますあっはっ
スモークが違うやーい本当に方はれネットに僕の名前入って無意識ってたらですね
オーナー
もう続いたら入ってそんなことないんですよ絶対ブロックリエンゾにいる
依存でなことしない分としない分溜まったも入ってましたすいませんその時も方があの
大観の例えば東京の体育館の撮影に行った時に一緒にきましたね
もともと駐車場の場所は記事なんかあるよっていうことを聞いてたんですけど
その周辺を運転していたら1時間ぐらい彷徨って駐車場なかったときはその他ねそれ
じゃああー
8ちょっと覚えされる中にちょっとですね
前の職場で本質があるんですけどマーチャント
防犯カメラもついてる上で財布を自分のロッカーに入れた出せば帰ろうと思ってまぁ
10スカウトも財布見てますけどお金札束だけ全部ないですよ
データ防犯カメラれたらわかるじゃないですか見てますけど仲間ですたいです皇室の
入口しか吐けなくて誰だ盗んだかも6月芸人時代のスパイなんですか
あああれ何回解散したんですってえっと実施した分後ロッカーやしてるんですけど
あ車の中でスマホ落としてナビがば上品はれたんですよ
それは不幸ですことさ
普通そんな掘ったら昔のショートばデー
同僚が辞めたんですけどやめたりをちょっと調子に聞いてみたら
僕からのラインがいやだって理由やめてっ
こうというアレですよ離婚するんですよああそうですリボンしますねはいというわけで
ですねちょっとほんとで今パッと思い出せないくらいものすごいよの心配になっちゃう
と逆に
でもやっぱり今年は本当にやっぱりもう一さん含め畑メンバー含め全員に迷惑かけたく
ない人も誰に対しはもう作ってみたかったん
踏まえてちゃんとを払い北に移動してるんでじゃあ巳年てからは何とこんなにもをして
ないんでねほんとただをなってを乾かしてください
頑張ります復興逆にですよいい考え方はというとみんなそこをかぶってるっていう
考え方を受けているので一概に悪いと言うんですけど
交通事故だけはマジで笑えないのに遅いぞ屋本店ちょ
素材ほど気をつけるんです知ったわけでえ見てる皆さんも交通事故だけはほんとに
ちょっと危ないんでぜひ気をつけてください
願いしますだけど皆さんお父様ですゴッチさんの不幸を楽しみ
今年不幸じゃないっ
me
あっはぁ